there's something that's not vibing with
me and I don't know what it is the fact
that there's no milk in it yeah it's
probably so a crazy sight creamy I want
a clink should think it just tastes like
melted play-doh when you accidentally
leave something plastic on the burner in
your house and you start to smell it
tastes bad
really I'm totally fine with this I can
eat this alone I'll go out alone yeah
just alone by myself in my room if I
think it's kind of good well near a
vegan it tastes like chemicals
it doesn't yeah I don't I think I would
rather have milk and diarrhea than
chemicals
he's like a spoonful of cold soft
almonds yeah I'm gonna find oh yeah
there's what I keep saying like I'm not
a fan of if I keep eating it so maybe
I'm a fan of it it's the sad desperate
smell of a new beginning no this is
awful
it tastes exactly like birthday cake
frost oh this is the worst one it's got
so much sugar in it for no reason Oh bad
for a second it just tasted like a rice
krispies treat that would have been good
if that if it always tasted like a rice
krispies treat then I'd be on board but
it was just there and gone oh god I
don't like that no no plastic
well--don't awful Oh what is that this
is like an ice slushy chemical bath this
is an insult to ice cream something
anything could save this why would you
eat this by the way it's not just
vanilla it's vanilla island huh what I
the island well they put a lot of care
into this packaging so they want you to
think that this is like good for you
that this is gonna improve your chakras
and your your your change oh oh it's a
daiquiri
you put a little little rum in this you
get real drunk real quick it just it
tastes good but also it tastes like a
lotion smells like something I want to
rub on my skin so if you want like a
coconut cream pie in ice cream form yeah
get this yep we did it it's so good
we did it America we made an ice cream
that's decent to eat muscle smells kind
of like poop I feel like it definitely
for me it tastes better than the
chocolate ice creams that you get like
an ice cream truck just tastes like I
opened up a cocoa powder box just
started shoveling it in my mouth which
some people might love batter you shove
it in there yeah oops important but so
is good ice cream